now the conflict in Ukraine is
overshadowing celebrations marking the
day Soviet forces defeated Nazi Germany
here we can see well not just there but
Russian President Vladimir Putin is
attending the procession along with six
leaders from former Soviet block
countries our festivities have been
scaled back across Russia Following last
week's alleged drone attack on the
Kremlin which Moscow called an attempt
on Putin's life
Let's cross over now to Yulia
Chapo valova he's standing by Forest and
you know just to give us an idea of how
important this day is to President
Vladimir Putin
well obviously it is very important not
just for President Putin but for the
whole of uh the whole Russian population
because uh basically at this holiday uh
still unites all the people of Russia as
well as people who participated in that
a war so the parade this year honoring
the 78th anniversary of victory in the
Great Patriotic War that's how people or
the former Soviet Union call their part
a World War II which began in June 1941
and finished in 1945 so the parade has
now taken place on Red's Queen Moscow
and Russian president commander-in-chief
Vladimir Putin will traditionally speak
at the event
I'm more than 10 000 troops and 125
units of military equipment are taking
part in the parade the security is also
tightened uh so we know that this parade
is being attended by seven of foreign
leaders as we understand presidents of
uh Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan
Uzbekistan Turkmenistan Belarus and
Prime Minister of Armenia are present
there all of them are independent
countries now but they used to be part
of this Soviet Union and fought with the
Nazis so obviously as we say the
security is very tight now and these
seven presidents seven foreign leaders
uh probably the
obviously they signaled that they they
are the best guaranteers rather of the
security on Red Square today and that we
can see in the college defense
ministergeogue addressing or saluting
his troops there in Red Square
celebrations for the Victory Day parade
in Moscow we are expecting Yulia
Vladimir Putin to give a speech as he
does every year what do we think he's
going to be saying in that speech today
what message does he have for the people
of Russia
uh well actually people do not expect
anything extraordinary this time around
so he's going to talk about uh Unity
he's going to talk about
the legacy of the Soviet Union or the
Soviet Union and Russia uh by the way in
a number of Russian regions it was
decided not to hold parades for security
reasons as this year the preparations
for victory they were taking place in a
tense atmosphere and Moscow accused Kiev
and its Western allies of a series of
Terror attacks so probably Putin will
also mention that and as we remember
among the latest of that tax it was on
the May the 3rd it was a drone attack on
the Kremlin which authorities described
as an attempted attack on the president
and also the procession of the immortal
regiment has been canceled throughout
the country in many places rather due to
security reasons and at this event pays
tribute to the memory of those who died
during the war their relatives now take
to the main streets of their cities and
towns holding portraits of their loved
ones who died obviously the Soviet Union
paid with the lives of more than 25
million people for victory in the World
War II
um
so basically uh people are just going to
to watch the parade and uh stay at home
sometimes honoring and and remembering
those who died because obviously it is a
day of mourning it is a day of the
remembrance and people are just going to
uh to to remember all those Fallen well
I was going to ask you about that Julia
because it is a public holiday this is
an annual event in Russia how widely is
it respected by the Russian people
well obviously this holiday is hugely
supported by the Russian people even
though there are some critics of the
parade itself and people say that mostly
it is it looks like
um saber rattling rather because Russia
wants to Showcase
its armor including weapons of mass
destruction instead of showing the world
that this is the day of remembrance and
mourning and uh and uh well actually in
the past it used to be like that because
uh Victory Day parades were held only
four times during the Soviet during
Soviet time
normally military parades used to take
place on November the 7th when the
Soviet Union was celebrating the great
October socialist Revolution and uh well
as as I said as I mentioned earlier that
was a day of remembrance made benign
siming so and everything changed with
President Boris Yeltsin because the the
Soviet Union ceased to be ceased to
exist and the 7th of November actually
lost any sense so and uh here in Russia
people needed a day of unity a day of
you know a holiday that will unite all
the people of Russia so basically okay
Julia
Putin has just taken the podium we are
expecting him to address the crowds
there in Red Square in a moment and
we'll just listen in to this event
dear fellow Russian citizens dear
veterans
comrade soldiers
sergeants and sergeant majors meet
shipment and warrant officers comrade
offices generals and admirals
the servicemen of the special military
operation I congratulate you on the this
holiday the day of great victory
of our parents grandparents and great
grandparents who glorified an immortal
internalized their names
but thanks to their feet we have saved
the humanity from Nazism today the
civilization is at the Turning Point
there's again a war against our
motherlands
but we have counted the international
terrorism we will protect donbas
residents and we will protect our
country
for
Russia there are no unfriendly Nations
neither in the west nor in the east
like the majority of people would like
to see bright free and stable future
we think that any ideology if of
Supremacy is abnormal
is Criminal and Mortal although
irrespective of that the Western
Elites are talking about their Supremacy
they're bringing people to clashes
they're seizing hatreds
they are destroying the family
Traditional Values that make people a
human a human
and basis with one goal to dictate their
will
to the Nations
to give orders to the whole world
they probably forgot what Nazism brought
to us the forgot who crushed that
horrible evil who protected their
motherlands and who gave their lives to
free
the people of Europe we see that in many
countries
they are now destroying the memorials to
the Soviet soldiers
they're destroying
memorials to Great victors
they are destroying the memory
of real heroes and they're rewriting the
history
this is also a crime
this is like a Revenge
of those who have who have been trying
to go against Russia again who have
joined the Nazis
and this is nothing new they are trying
to destroy our country
they are trying to make us forget the
results of the second world war and to
destroy the
global security system and international
order they want to stifle any Sovereign
Center of development
they think they can do anything and this
leads to tragedies
that's why we see the catastrophe that
is happening in Ukraine
the prisoners of the cool that happens
and also of the criminal regime that
succeeded it
here in Russia we remember the protect
us of the motherlands we keep it in our
hearts
the Warriors of resistance who fought
against Nazism we also honor the Allies
the US the UK
we're also owner the victory the
people of China
who fought alongside us
this is our Legacy
and this is our foundation especially
now
that we're moving towards a more
just and multilateral
multilateral world
where all of us can develop freely and
independently
it is important that here in Moscow we
have leaders from the
CIS countries
and I can say that
this is
every everyone who won during the war
all the peoples of the USSR contributed
to our Victory and we will always
remember about it we bow our heads to
the memory of those who died and was
killed in the war to the daughters Sons
mothers fathers grandparents husbands
wives brothers
sisters relatives and Friends
I declare a minute of Silence
foreign
thank you
fellow Russian citizens
the decisive battles for our motherlands
have always become sacred
we listen to our ancestors
we follow their lessons we know how to
be at their level
how to become them we're proud of the
participants of the special military
operations everyone who is fighting on
the front lines
who is sacrificing their lives to save
other someone else
you are now
the Protectors of our motherlands
our people's Safety and Security depends
on on you
you're fighting for Russia
your families your children friends and
behind you they are waiting for you I'm
sure you're feeling the unlimited love
the whole country is United to support
our heroes
everyone is ready to help we're praying
for you
friends dear veterans
today every family owners the
participants of the Great Patriotic War
we remember our heroes our relatives
we're bringing flowers to the memorials
today
we stand on the lands of our ancestors
the Warriors of pizza the great and
kutus
will remember the parades of 1941 and
today you have participants of the
special military operations
there are soldiers there are draftmen
they're the middle the Warriors from the
dawn bus
divisions
National Guards
the Federal Security Service and other
ministers and departments I welcome you
I welcome everyone who is fighting for
Russia on the battlefield
I welcome everyone who is now in service
and on duty
our heroic ancestors proved to us that
nothing can be stronger than our Unity
nothing in the world can be stronger
than our love to the motherland for
Russia for our Armed Forces
for for the victory hooray
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
spiritual
battalion
[Applause]
this country
oh
[Music]
it was Global is
and that we've been watching pictures
from moscow's Red Square of Russia's
annual Victory Day parade this is
commemorating the 1945 Soviet victory
over Nazi Germany it's a crucial day in
President Vladimir Putin's leadership he
calls it the Great Patriotic War and
it's the vision of Putin of Putin's
vision of Russian identity we heard him
speaking they're addressing members of
the military and crowds they're in Red
Square talking about a real war
currently being waged against the
motherland Western Elites he said trying
to destroy our country they seem he said
forgot Nazism and who crushed it and
that's why he said they are seeing the
catastrophe in Ukraine let's bring in
Julia
she's also listening into the speech
watching events there in Moscow and
Yulia this is a message that the Russian
people will be very familiar with
oh absolutely absolutely so he basically
reiterated something that that he has
already said many times before so once
again he blamed the Western countries in
russophobia uh blames them for
supporting uh supporting uh Ukraine and
basically they blame them for the whole
conflict in Ukraine the well he also
mentions that the Western countries they
always suppress freedom and other
countries and basically he also praised
the participants of the of the special
military operation in Ukraine and he
said that obviously they are those who
will bring peace and stability to Russia
and Russia is moving towards its uh
bright and just and fair future that's
according to Vladimir Putin so nothing
new nothing special well once again of
course he praised all the veterans of
World War II and to read Patriotic War
here in Russia and the whole Soviet
Union so basically the same the same
kind of rhetoric
these celebrations they will be toned
down slightly this year won't they from
previous years just give us an idea of
how that has happened and why
so in many cities and towns of Russia uh
military parades have been canceled
whatsoever as well as the march of the
immortal regiment when people are
carrying portraits of their loved ones
of those who died during World War II
they usually were pouring onto the
streets of various Russian cities and
towns and actually normally it is
supposed to be a day of remembrance so
now the authorities ask them to stay at
home or probably to to
um
show their loved ones put them on their
windows and and on their cars and well
they they just warned them not to to go
onto the street because because
basically it's quite dangerous according
to them because the situation in country
is quite tense and so basically this is
just a security measure so this is a
nation at War they will leave it for now
the celebrations for Victory Day the end
of 1945 World War II celebrations there
in moscow's Red Square
foreign
[Music]